c'était un fleuron de l'industrie à
cherbourg qui a compté jusqu'à 500
salariés l'entreprise si mon frère a
trouvé refuge sur la base navale dans un
atelier autrefois occupé par la marine
et c'est ici qu'elle vit une nouvelle
jeunesse avec ses machines uniques qui
ont toujours fait la réputation de la
maison des machines à fabriquer le
beurre qui sont aujourd'hui vendus
partout dans le monde
ce fut d'abord une entreprise prospère
qui a équipé les fermes de france en
outillage de toutes sortes presse
concasseuse et crémeuse et puis si mon
frère a conquis le monde avec une
machine révolutionnaire capable de
fabriquer le beurre en continu je veux
vous parler de quelqu'un qui est un cas
d'ailleurs été invité par le président
la république parmi les 22 champions de
la petite et moyenne entreprise
il s'agit de monsieur simon la recette
c'est d'abord d'avoir un produit
construit à charlesbourg des machines à
fabriquer le beurre est un produit que
l'on adapte dans chaque pays
sans surprise les salariés ont appris ce
matin que leur entreprise déposé
officiellement son bilan à 11 heures
mauvais geste sur entraînement avec les
quotas laitiers européens le marché
s'est soudainement retourné en 1988
c'est la chute brutale malgré une
restructuration douloureuse malgré une
diversification dans le nucléaire
si mon frère ne cesse de décliner et en
2004 l'entreprise dépose encore le bilan
mais il était dit que l'histoire ne
s'arrêterait pas là dix ans plus tard
l'entreprise a retrouvé des couleurs en
se recentrant sur son métier d'origine
elle a aussi renoué avec une philosophie
maison si mon frère conçoit fabrique et
vend des machines clés en main ça c'est
une machine qui partirent au
moyen-orient donc dans un endroit où il
y a pas forcément de l'est en abondance
donc elle utilisera des blocs de beurre
et là en l'occurrence c'est une ligne
qui a été spécifiquement conçu pour un
besoin particulier d'un client la
méthode porte ses fruits aujourd'hui
l'entreprise qui appartient au groupe
bretèche n'emploie que 35 salariés mais
le carnet de commandes est plein ça sert
à l'exclusion du beurre pour malaxer
l'obr comme il était mal à ces autrefois
manuellement les poussées par 2 par
davis à travers ces trous et malaxer par
des élèves pour lui donner sa texture
définitive
il faut compter deux à trois mois pour
adapter les plans d'une machine et
encore trois mois pour la fabriquer
l'atelier en assemblée une quinzaine
chaque année on travaille toujours sur
des pièces uniques cette pièce là elle
est unique elle a des spécificités
qu'aucune autre n'aura si on fabriquait
des séries on pourrait voir apparaître
sur le marché les clients qui seraient
capables de copier la série est alors
forcément d'être moins cher que nous
parce que pas de développement pas de
technologues pas de commerciaux alors
que nous on vend pas de machine
innovants des procédés au vent
l'aptitude d'un ensemble de machines à
fabriquer un produit spécifique que le
client recherche aujourd'hui si mon
frère gagner de l'argent ces machines
sont vendus au moyen-orient en russie au
japon ou en afrique
un gros contrat a été remporté cet été
au mexique d'autres sont espérés cet
hiver en inde et l'entreprise
cherbourgeoise continue de gérer
l'héritage l'entretien du parc de
machines en fonctionnement sur tous les
continents assure 30% du chiffre
d'affaires
voilà donc l'ensemble des pièces qu'on
peut continuer de fournir à nos clients
donc on ressort les plans de l'époque et
on refabriquer pièce à l'identique
l'entreprise recrute en trois ans la
moitié du personnel a été renouvelé en
raison des départs en retraite
elles recherchent encore un chaudronnier
et un monteur pour aller installer les
machines dans les usines du monde entier
avis aux amateurs c'est normand c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui à la semaine
prochaine